le 6 avril un coup ça me fait plaisir de
vous retrouver ici à kiev ça m'a fait
vraiment plaisir que vous êtes ici
accueil est vrai que vous avez
l'opportunité
de voir un peu le pays et de voir
comment ça se passe à peu près dans tous
les partis qui sont vraiment affecté par
cette guerre d'agression russe ce matin
on a vu un défilé à moscou pour le 9 mai
vladimir poutine rejette toute la
responsabilité de cette guerre il dit
que la menace était trop importante donc
c'est la faute de l'occident comment
vous réagissez ce qui s'est passé ce
matin mais c'est comme d'habitude il n'a
rien dit de nouveau il n'a rien dit
d'intéressant on a entendu cette
cassette la tournée plusieurs fois
plusieurs jours plusieurs années c'est
toujours la faute de quelqu'un mais pas
de poutine et pas de la russie ont
témoigné ce moment les paroles d'un
dirigeant un peu lunatique et un peu
obsédé par le pouvoir et surtout un
dirigeant autoritaire qui voudraient
bien rétablir les empires mais ça fait
soixante quinze jours que ça dure ce
conflit maintenant quel bilan vous
faites ce doit être extrêmement fatigant
c'est fatigant c'est dur mais nous les
ukrainiens on n'a pas d'autre choix que
de pousser à la victoire et on le fait
avec tous les réseaux qu'on a ici on est
vraiment reconnaissante pour toute
l'assistance l'aide qu'on reçoit de
l'étranger de nos alliés mais c'est
important aussi de de comprendre que le
plus long que ça dure le plus loin on
sera de la victoire puisque poutine joue
à son jeu qu'il a commencé en 2014
quand il fait semblant de retirer ses
forces de localiser la guerre de
localiser les zones de combat et après
ce qu'on voit c'est que la tension
s'est diminue autour de lui prenne le
soutien aussi il ya ça commence à se
diminuer puisque les guerres longues ça
coûte cher pour tout le monde et donc
moi je crains que ces jeux lac poutine
est en train de jouer avec le monde
entier vous créez une fatigue de la
communauté internationale et la
communauté internationale une fatigue en
cours à nancy et
tout ça c'est un grand grand risque pour
la victoire de la démocratie
on va vraiment à ce moment là on doit
vraiment mobiliser tous les efforts du
monde entier pour pour avoir plus d
armement en ukraine pour avoir vraiment
des sanctions effectives et trop fortes
contre la russie et à voir surtout un
soutien économique pour l'ukraine
on n'a pas de temps on doit avoir cette
victoire au plus vite possible
est-ce que vous pensez que si l'occident
et j'inclus le canada bien sûr la dent
avait agi plus vite avait aidé plus
l'ukraine et plus vite on aurait pu
sauver des vies en grève je suis sûr de
ça tout le monde a fait un choix et
maintenance tout ce qui se passe ici en
ukraine au milieu de l'europe au milieu
du xxème siècle c'est la responsabilité
collective du monde entier qui a pas pu
agir autant aujourd'hui on voit ce qui
se passe encore un mario paul ait encore
des soldats ukrainien qui résiste est ce
que il va falloir qu'il capitule devant
la russie est ce que c'est comme ça que
ça va se terminer selon vous ils n'ont
pas de choix encore une fois l oncle que
ça peut se battre pour
soit gagné une victoire ou se battre à
la mort
ce sont les paroles de ces de ce
combattant de ces soldats
du bataillon d'azov ils disent qu'ils
n'ont pas peur de mourir mais son port
de d'être pris en otage d'être
prisonnier par l'armée russe pourquoi
parce que ça serait pire que de nourrir
pour eux que ça serait beaucoup plus
pire pour ils vont être interrogés
ils vont être torturés ça va être norme
est mort très lente et une mort très
douleureuse pour eux ils craignent aussi
qu avec leur identité si c'est déjà
je vu par les russes leur famille et
leurs gens proches vont être en danger
aussi au début de ce conflit on a vu des
images de vous était armé avec une
mitraillette ça avait beaucoup marqué
les esprits de voir
une jeune parlementaire comme vous
prendre les armes est ce que ça vous a
servi j'ai toujours mes armes je suis
très heureuse de ne pas devoir du mont
se relire avec c'était vraiment les
semaines la première mois de de cette
guerre à quand les russes c'était tout
près de kiev avant c était très près de
kiev vous avez pu de témoigner quand
vous étalez abouti à et reprise c'est
vraiment très très près c'est
pratiquement qu'il donc il y avait ces
risques ces risques vraiment très haut
et il valait mieux d'avoir une arme pour
pouvoir se protéger à ce moment là la
situation a changé vous voyez très bien
la vie continue la ville et revient même
avec les sons de guerre un pur
background mais de toute façon c'est
beaucoup plus calme ah c'est beaucoup
plus sécurisée donc vous voyez moi je ne
porte pas de sac à main avec un plus
grand c'est plus c'est plus la même
chose mais vraiment la guerre continue
toujours vous avez dénoncé justement les
viols comme arme de guerre
de l'armée russe
quelle est l'ampleur de ce phénomène les
russes ils utilisent le viol comme une
arme de guerre il le faisait pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale
ils le font maintenant six donc rien à
changer pour vraiment un pour
une femme et une personne d'être violée
parce qu'ils les risques violer les
femmes les enfants les hommes à
ccc pire que d'être tué et quand j'ai
violé
tué victime pour le reste de ta vie
puisque c était un crime qui a été
commis contre toi contre ton corps
et c'est à cette marque en plus c'est
bien là c'est pas juste
c'est fait pour briser la résistance
résistance est fait pour briser la
personne se fait pour briser les
familles les communautés puisque si
violent il se passe
devant les devants les autres gens
devant ta famille on a plein de cadres
des viols qui où il y avait les filles
étaient violées devant leur mère ou les
mères étaient violées devant leur fils
donc quand la famille ou la communauté
doit survivre à ça il y a à tout un
bagage qui reste et qui avec lequel on
sait pas quoi faire puisqu'il ya
toujours ce sentiment de
doute de honte de culpabilité de honte
et de culpabilité puisque ça s'est passé
devant mes yeux n'est pas rien pu faire
pour protéger mon enfant où j'ai pu rien
faire pour protéger cette femme qui est
ma voisine dans ma communauté
comment est ce que je peux vivre après
avec cela donc c'est tout ce qui reste
après les crimes des viols c'est tout un
henri band
de problèmes qui vont qui vont se
dérouler pendant des années et des
années peut-être pendant des générations
en terminant vous pensez que les crèmes
va résister jusqu'au bout est ce qu'elle
peut gagner cette guerre l'ukraine doit
gagner cette guerre pour nom pour les
ukrainiens mais aussi pour le monde
entier dans lequel on est habitué à ce
livre reste
ce monde auquel on est habitué et reste
une place de
de paix de sécurité
on doit rétablir la paix et c'est ça ce
qui vient avec
avec la victoire les premières
laisser remercie beaucoup
nous avoir parlé aujourd'hui
bonne chance
merci merci